many people in russia have no idea what
their government is doing right now in
ukraine
they think they're liberating ukraine
not destroying it
moscow has banned facebook and twitter
to make it easier to sell its
lies one of the weak points of
autocracies is that they rely on total
control of information
so we'll continue our efforts to counter
russian disinformation
and expose the true cost of this war to
the russian people
both the profound costs to ukraine and
the ukrainian people and the costs to
russian people themselves which are
mounting every single day
the ruble is cratered
mastercard visa apple pay has shut down
dozens of leading companies from nike to
coca-cola
fedex to spotify
netflix to toyota have exited the
country
president putin is making russia a
pariah
destroying in the space of a week
30 years
of international openness
and opportunity
the russian people are already feeling
the effects of this in their everyday
lives
and that will increase
we hope they can learn the truth about
why this is happening
this is not the russian people's war
it's not a war of liberation or whatever
else they've been told
this is president putin's war to
subjugate a sovereign democratic country
and until he ends it the world will hold
him accountable
at this critical moment for democracy in
eastern europe
it is all the more important
that democracies like estonia
all of the baltics
continue to represent the better path
and rise to the challenge of the moment
the united states will stand with you as
you do
today i should note is
international women's day
and i'm very pleased to be in estonia uh
for it
because
as is very clearly being demonstrated
right now
estonia has remarkably strong
leaders who
or women
including its prime minister
including its foreign minister
and because of sony's commitment to
closing the gender pay gap
and advancing gender equality uh among
uh
other key metrics it's leading uh the
world in um in all of these areas
today uh we also think of the strength
of women in ukraine
hundreds of thousands of ukrainian women
have taken their children to safety
in other countries
often leaving
husbands behind
as well as many women who joined the
fight to protect the homeland themselves
the women of ukraine embody the
fortitude the resilience
the courage
of women everywhere